welcome back to las vegas now jack sally
and the rest of the gang have invaded
tom devlin's monster museum in boulder
city jc is back with more on this
family-friendly attraction hey jc
hey guys we are having fun at the
frightmare before christmas i got the
right money for christmas
with tom devlin the master of christmas
now what area are we in we are this is
christmas town
the only place you can play in the snow
in southern nevada yeah uh it's known in
boulder city by the way what is
christmas town as regards to the movie
christmas town is where santa's from in
the north pole and that part of the
holiday exists so jack takes over
christmas town and uh
the santa claus character gets kidnapped
and then and they go everything goes
haywire all right this is for the entire
family we're gonna go inside you can
lead the way buddy inside
kids of all ages there are no scares tom
dublin does like to do the scares he
promises no scares on this attraction
around the corner here wow
so many instagramable spots this area
what's the hallway here so we're we have
lock shock and barrel and they've
kidnapped santa claus in the drum here
that's in the movie right yeah that's
all from the moon they put them in a
drum they well they put them in a bag or
a box okay yeah let's go around the
corner here yeah
and then this is oogie boogie's lair
whoa
the actual oogie boogie from the movie
yeah that's oogie boogie so block chuck
and barrel deliver santa claus to oogie
boogie
you tell the tale of the whole entire
movie inside of this basically
in cliff notes sure the abbreviated
version come on
in here we have the uh lab where dr
finkelstein who built exactly
is hanging out
this is sally's last song basically that
uh that is warning jack to give
christmas back now we're looking at all
these creations you've built these all
on your own some are built some are uh
bought like this sally figure was
purchased but uh she fits the scene you
know you're i mean you really are a
master of your craft you got the grinch
out here on saturday up until christmas
this is running every day
uh this will be running every day
through december and then we have the
grinch on saturday perfect uh i love
that uh lance gets the a for effort
today because he's bumping himself left
and right because there's so much
happening here you're going to want to
turn around you want to turn around
lance we'll send it back to you guys
jack right up there he'll say goodbye to
you as you leave we'll send it back to
you guys in the studio we're having a
blast out here